food poisoning is also known as
foodborne illness and this is caused by
several microorganisms which results in
diarrhea and abdominal discomfort
in this video we'll talk about the
symptoms diagnosis and the treatment of
food poisoning
let's talk about the symptoms which
includes
abdominal cramp dysuria or lumbar pain
diarrhea nausea or vomiting sensation
headache fever weakness and loss of
appetite in case of extreme cases of
food poisoning there could be fever
which is more than 102 degree fahrenheit
there could be diarrhea which lasts
longer than three days
in extreme cases there could be
difficulty in seeing or speaking severe
dehydration and bloody urine but things
doesn't turn out to be so bad
and these are only some extreme
situations
if we talk about the pathology of food
poisoning the most common causative
agents are bacteria
sometimes viruses and in most rare cases
there could be parasites as well
now
every year lot of people who are
traveling all across the world
experience this kind of food poisoning
and travellers diarrhea
while they
kind of sample food from the local
stores and local street food
so it is caused by
eating contaminated food with these
microorganisms or drinking some water
which is contaminated with viruses or
parasites let's say
you have the increased chance of
developing a food poisoning and traveler
diarrhea especially if you are visiting
from a western world to the developing
countries so the things the climates the
sanitary practices all are pretty
different that means the exposure to
microorganism is higher in these cases
which might lead to
development of food poisoning now let us
talk about the name of those bacteria
which are most common for
food poisoning it involves
estrogen coli which is also present in
our own elementary canal and this is a
bacteria which is kind of friendly but
sometimes some species of these
escherichia coli can also cause food
poisoning other than campylobacter
jejuni
salmonella clostridium
then there is listeria staphylococcus
and shigella along with salmonella can
cause
food poisoning among all of these
bacteria the most common cause
the most common bacteria involves
salmonella shigella campylobacter and
clostridium
now campylobacter jejuni is the leading
cause of food-borne disease in united
states
now it's also
it transfers
by
touching contaminated stool or
by eating some food which might be
contaminated with these campylobacter
jejuni bacteria
it causes severe discomfort in
the intestinal part
and that can lead to several problems
next candidate is shigella
shigella selectively destroy the mucosal
lining of the large intestine that leads
to the bloody diarrhea that means blood
in your stool
chances of shigellosis or shigella born
food poisoning is very common in
case of old and young people because
they have relatively weaker immune
system clostridium perfringens is
another bacteria which is a severe cause
of food-borne illness clostridium
perfringens can form endospores
endospores are resistant to heat that
means even in the cooked food they can
still be there and it's a leading cause
of food poisoning in usa cdc estimates
that this bacteria can cause nearly one
million of cases in united states every
year
and clostridium perfringens are mostly
found in raw meat and poultry products
now in all of these bacterial infection
the toxins present in the bacteria might
lead to this kind of discomfort that
anybody experiences the abdominal cramp
and all these
and all these gi tract discomforts
now let's talk about the viruses as a
cause of these uh food poisoning there
are many viruses reported to cause food
poisoning such as norovirus rotavirus
astrovirus sapovirus and hepatitis a
virus among them most common ones are
the norovirus
and in usa alone there are 2 500
reported norovirus outbreak cases
and anyway there is a particular season
where no virus mediated food poisoning
is really really common
in rare occasions there could be
parasites as well which might lead to
food poisoning
and these parasites includes toxoplasma
tinia and many others but among all of
these parasites teenia sajnata and tinia
solium are the most common ones
so
uncooked beef uncooked pork or uncooked
fish might have these step worms which
might lead to food poisoning and other
abdominal problems
question is how long does the food
poisoning last it can last from few
hours
to few weeks but in most common cases
all the symptoms are resolved within a
week of time
the diagnosis is pretty simple if you
have symptoms like vomiting nausea and
abdominal cramps most likely you got a
food poisoning but in extreme cases you
might need a blood test stool test or
urine test along with the food that
you have eaten
treatment option includes several
antibiotics so obviously there are
several symptoms associated with
bacterial
the bacterial
food poisoning is most common and the
symptoms can be relieved with the help
of
antibiotics and you can put ors because
lot of
fluid is lost during this uh diarrhea
that means replenishing that fluid is
really important and diarrhea is
key cause of death in many developing
countries
so all the bacteria would be resolved if
we treat you with antibiotic but in some
cases when the infection is not caused
by the bacteria then
there are no other options for example
in case of viral uh infections that
cause to that cause uh food poisoning
that generally
heals up on its own and it takes like
two to three days sometimes a week
in several in case of protozoa diarrhea
things might take a little bit longer
but anyway overall these food poisoning
and its symptoms are highly treatable
we should not ignore food poisoning or
we should not also get scared with food
poisoning
so many notes and flash cards are
associated
associated with these videos are found
in my facebook page follow my facebook
page where you would get many dynamic
flash cards don't forget to like share
and subscribe you can support me on page